Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit.
And we are still
blazing a trail.
For those who take their fate
into their own hands
by working hard...
Sproing is the next
big thing
in fitness.
Whoo‐whoo!
Narrator:
...by working smart...
This is gonna be the number‐one
item on baby registries.
‐Who thinks of these things?
‐That's smart.
Narrator: ...by thinking big...
Moki Doorstep is here to give
you the boost you need.
Narrator:
...and chasing their dreams.
How long you been watching
"Shark Tank"?
Since I was
about 8 years old.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Wow!
Within months, you're gonna see
knock‐offs on this.
There's a real need for it
on the market.
We've got about $2 million
of our own money into this.
‐Wow!
It's a dog.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the tank
is a product
to give you a boost up
when you need it the most.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Zach Brown.
And my name
is Alyssa Brown.
We are from
Newington, Connecticut,
and we are seeking $150,000
in exchange for 5%
of our company,
Moki Doorstep.
Wow.
Sharks, at a mere
five feet tall,
I've always been
vertically challenged,
but most of the time, it doesn't
seem to hold me back.
I mean, being short
even has some perks,
like being the champ
at limbo...
[ Laughter ]
...or getting that prime,
front‐row spot
in the group photos.
Plus, I never hit my head
on anything, unlike Zach.
This is true,
but there's one thing
Alyssa has always
struggled with.
We are an
outdoor‐loving couple,
and most weekends
start off with us
loading up a kayak or skis
to go find an adventure.
Alyssa has never
been able to
easily secure the gear
on the roof of a car.
We didn't want that hassle
holding us back.
Plus, once we looked around,
a lot of other people st‐‐
struggled, much like us.
But struggle no more,
because we've invented
the Moki Doorstep.
The Moki Doorstep is a vehicle
rooftop‐assistance device.
This gives you that
quick and easy step up
to the top of your car.
Let me show you guys
how it works.
This hooks on in one second
to the striker of the vehicle,
which is standard
on most cars.
And I'm up just as quick.
‐Huh.
‐Wow.
‐Who thinks of these things?
‐Interesting.
‐That's smart.
‐We do! [ Chuckles ]
It unhooks just as quick
without any hassle.
[ Car door closes ]
So, whether you are
loading up
a mountain bike,
securing your family's
Christmas tree,
or clearing a foot of snow off
from that last storm,
Moki Doorstep is here
to give you the boost you need.
So, Sharks,
who wants to step up
to your next adventure
with Moki Doorstep?
Which short Shark wants
to come give it a try?
[ Laughter ]
We've got a sample for you.
‐The shortest one.
‐I'm a short Shark.
‐Well, come on!
‐But I'm in heels.
‐Robert!
‐Hey, it's a good challenge.
All right, we'll see.
[ Laughs ]
‐Ah.
‐Got a sample for you, sir.
Can I do it in heels?
That's all right. We'll ‐‐ We'll
pick someone else if you can't.
Here's a sample.
Thank you.
Herjavec: Wow. It's solid.
John: [ Chuckling ] It is ‐‐
This is a great idea.
‐Great idea. Congrats.
‐Thank you, sir.
Greiner: Okay.
Alyssa: So, you're gonna
hold it down like this.
And you're gonna just hook
underneath right there.
Oh.
Look at you.
Pretty cool.
The ingenuity
in America amazes me.
‐This is great.
‐Thank you, sir.
Who would have thought
somebody would think of this?
There you go, Lori.
Here's yours.
‐Oh, thank you.
‐You're welcome.
Like, how did you even...
So, I'm an
emergency‐room nurse.
Zach's a firefighter.
‐Ahh.
‐Oh.
‐Whoo‐whoo!
‐Thanks. I mean ‐‐
So, being a firefighter,
we use the Jaws of Life.
And we always try
to open the door this way.
And that bolt right there,
per standards,
has to hold 2,200 pounds,
so it's extremely strong.
So, using that knowledge,
I said,
"Hey, we can create
a device to step on it
to make access
much easier."
‐That's very smart.
‐Wow.
Cuban: So, what are your sales?
So, we did a Kickstarter
campaign back in January.
We ran a 30‐day campaign,
and we did $110,000
worth of sales.
Wow.
What are you selling them for?
What does it cost you to make?
So, we tol‐‐ We sold them
at a camping show,
between $40 and $50 to try
to figure out our price point.
Either prices hold
equally as well.
Our landed cost
is $10.50 for it.
So, what did you do annually?
So, we've only done
the $116,000 in sales.
Oh, you've only done
Kickstarter.
So, we only did the Kickstarter
and the camping show.
‐You only did Kickstarter. Okay.
‐I see.
So we're not
selling currently
because we're back‐ordered
from the other ones.
‐About 33 days.
‐Is this patented?
‐Patent pending.
‐Yes.
Sorry, Lori. I had ‐‐
I know somebody who did
something very similar.
‐You do?
‐Yeah.
What was similar?
Well, when I was growing up,
this guy in my neighborhood
named Pookie ‐‐
‐Oh, Lord.
‐[ Laughter ]
He had these ‐‐
these bunch of pedals
that he used to put
in his pockets,
so every time he, you know,
did something wrong,
when the cops would chase him,
he would put them
into the gates.
It was called the Pookie step.
‐[ Laughs ]
And he would just
get over the gate like that.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐He's doing 2 to 5 right now.
[ Laughter ]
Cuban: And his name is Pookie?
‐It's called the Pookie step.
‐Pookie!
The Pookie step.
Uh, why is it called the Moki?
The Pueblo Indians
would build Moki steps.
They would kind of
carve them out into the walls.
‐Oh.
So, that way, they could
kind of scurry up the walls.
So, let's quickly
get at the numbers here.
$150,000 for 5% imputes
a $3 million valuation.
That sounds a little rich
for something you just launched.
I need a Moki Step
to get to that.
So...
So, we actually had a CFO of
a very large auto‐parts company,
and he actually told us
we'd be crazy
to value under $4 million.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐So...
You know what I love
about guys like that?
They're not writing checks.
I‐I agree,
but on top of that,
we've also been talking
to a rack company, and they ‐‐
we have a term sheet
for a licensing agreement
for North America.
A rap company?
‐A rack company.
‐Oh, "rack."
Yep. He wants to do
a 7‐year deal.
Minimums would be
$3 million for that 7 years.
‐You will make $3 million?
‐Yes.
Herjavec:
On royalties to you?
O'Leary: What's he gonna
pay you in royalties ‐‐ 7%?
Actually, 12.5%, sir.
Herjavec: What's the guarantee?
Is there a guarantee to it?
Cuban: Yeah, the minimum he said
was $3 million in royalties.
‐Right, so, it's minimums.
‐Yeah, we have yearly minimums.
So, for the licensing
agreement,
if he does not perform
to those minimums,
we can walk away
from the licensing agreement.
But you did a lic‐‐
So, you've already licensed it.
We have not.
We have a term sheet.
We're talking in it,
so we're kind of ‐‐
‐Talking.
‐We're talking.
How much money
have you guys invested so far?
$30,000.
So, my uncle and I
went in together.
He ended up filing
the initial provisional patent.
He then signed the patent
over to me, and the company,
and now, out of our sales,
he gets a $1‐per‐step royalty
I give to him.
Oh, so, your uncle gets $1
for each piece sold.
‐Yep. Yeah.
‐Yes.
‐Is that in perpetuity?
‐Forever? Forever?
It's for 18 more years.
‐18 more years?
‐18 years?
Greiner: Wow.
Well, it's attached
to the patent.
You have an uncle like Kevin?
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
and they've discovered
that Zach and Alyssa must pay
a royalty to Zach's uncle
for helping them
launch Moki Step,
a step to help
reach the top of vehicles.
It's for 18 more years.
‐18 more years?
If you do the distribution deal
with the 12.5% royalty to it,
does that cut you off
from selling it anywhere else?
So, that deal would just be
a North American deal.
So the rest of the world's
still out there.
I wouldn't pay
50 bucks for this.
I would pay $19.95,
maybe less.
Within months, you're gonna see
knock‐offs on this.
You should be trying to figure
out how to make it for less
because someone else
is gonna do it.
I'm out.
Zach, I think you should
take the distribution deal.
There's no risk to you.
You're guaranteed money.
If they fall
a little bit short,
you can take the product back
and go to market with it.
Yep.
I mean, why wouldn't you
do that deal?
So, here's why we're here.
In the world, there's about
a billion registered vehicles.
Only a quarter of those
are in the United States.
We want to look
at the big picture
outside the United States
and North America.
So you want to take this deal
and work with us to go global.
‐Yes.
‐Right.
Well, I'm interested in it.
I have connections
with Cox Automotive.
I'll give you
$450,000 for 20%.
Herjavec: $450,000, 20%.
$2.2 million value.
You're asking
for a $3 million value.
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐Right.
Okay.
What do you guys think?
I'd say we're not willing
to go to 20%.
20% is a lot of equity
to give up for ‐‐
John: It's a lot of money.
I understand that, but for ‐‐
for that amount of equity,
I think we'd be better off
just selling it outright.
If ‐‐ If the offer was right,
I‐I'd sell it.
So, what would you sell
the whole company for outright?
Well, came in here
with a 3 million dol‐‐
$3 million valuation,
so that's ‐‐
I mean, I'd try
to stick around that.
Greiner: $3 million.
I can buy the whole thing
for $3 million?
We'd be willing to, I mean,
definitely come down to the
$3 million or go around there...
It's a re‐‐ We get it.
It's a newer company.
...because we want to be ‐‐
I mean, we enjoy our jobs.
Baby number ‐‐
Baby number two
is on the way.
Yeah. That, too.
‐Oh, congratulations!
‐Ah!
A few million dollars
in the bank goes a long way.
[ Laughter ]
John: If you have
that contract in place,
I will offer you right now
$3 million
for the entire company.
Wow.
With that licensing
agreement in place?
Yeah.
And you'll handle
the $1 royalty to our uncle?
Yes.
You got to pay
Uncle Moki forever.
Greiner: Wow.
We'll deal with Uncle Moki
on how long because ‐‐
‐Let's do it.
‐We're doing it.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, my gosh!
[ Laughter ]
‐All right.
‐Wow!
‐Congratulations.
‐Thank you.
‐Try it out, Daymond.
‐You got to try it now!
‐Alyssa.
‐Yes?
How does it feel
to be a millionaire?
I don't know!
[ Laughter ]
Riding all the way
to the bank, baby.
‐Yeah!
‐Yeah! Whoo!
Whoo!
‐All right.
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Yes. Thank you.
‐Thank you.
‐Whoo!
‐Holy...
Hey, good job.
Oh, my God.
Alyssa: We've enjoyed
running the business,
but we really enjoy our jobs
and being with our family,
so we can
make money off of it
and go back
to our normal lives.
I love you so much.
I love you, too.
That's awesome.
Oh, my God.
Whew.
[ Both laugh ]
[ Sniffles ] That's wild.
Daymond,
I got bad news for you.
What? What's that?
Mr. Wonderful is gonna
knock this off
and sell it for nine bucks,
and you can sue me
all over town if you want.
♪♪
Narrator:
In season five, Bruno Francois
made a deal with Mark Cuban
for his hands‐free panoramic
photo app Cycloramic.
Let's see what he's up to now.
Francois: I made a deal
five years ago on "Shark Tank,"
and it has not been
an easy journey.
Within an hour of airing,
Cycloramic became #1
in the App Store worldwide,
and my sales went up
to $1.5 million.
But after a year,
sales really dropped,
and I tried to do
other consumer apps,
but the chance that I would
achieve success with another app
would be like lightning striking
twice in the same place.
Luckily, I was able
to use my technology
to create 360‐degree
scans of cars.
So Cycloramic became
my new business, Car360.
You can rotate, you can zoom in,
you can click on hot spots.
When we launched,
we generated over $1 million
just within a few months.
Ooh, I like that.
I like that.
When I met Ernie Garcia,
CEO of Carvana,
an online car marketplace,
we realized our technology
was perfectly aligned.
He made me an offer
I couldn't refuse.
Carvana has just acquired Car360
for $22 million
in cash and stocks.
Cuban: What's up, guys?
When Bruno came on five years
ago with Cycloramic,
I saw it was more than
just a little iPhone app.
I knew that he had
some advanced technology
and that it could
go places from there.
Francois: You can click
on any features you want,
and you can see
all the details.
When you introduce 3‐D models
and the ability to re‐create it
in an augmented‐reality
environment,
the geek in me
is very, very happy.
Bruno, I'm so proud of you.
Bruno just may be the
number‐one success story
out of "Shark Tank."
Not necessarily that $22 million
is the biggest acquisition,
but the company basically
had to reinvent itself
and go from zero
to $22 million.
That's the American dream.
That's the "Shark Tank" dream.
Well done.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
is what the entrepreneurs hope
is the next hot trend
in fitness.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Paul Toback.
I'm Steve Lenz, and our company
is Sproing Fitness.
We're from Chicago, Illinois,
and we're seeking
a $500,000 investment
for an 8% stake in our company.
‐Wow.
Sharks, running remains the most
popular form of cardio workout,
but with 85% of runners
injured every year,
as runners ourselves,
we had to ask,
"What are we doing wrong?"
The short answer is,
we're running the wrong way.
And ‐‐ spoiler alert ‐‐
the treadmill is a big part
of the problem.
Everybody that runs has to fall
forward in order to move.
But, in the case
of a treadmill,
the ground is moving
underneath you,
making it virtually
impossible to fall forward.
Instead, the treadmill
causes you to land
out ahead of your body
on your heel,
pounding your knees, your hips,
your back, your ankles.
This is the number‐one cause
of injury in runners.
We knew there
had to be a better way,
so we reinvented
the treadmill.
Introducing Sproing...
‐Ta‐da.
‐Whoo‐hoo!
...the first new running machine
in over 100 years.
Sproing replaces the treadmill's
hard wooden deck
with a soft, impact‐absorbing
air cushion
and lets you feel like
you're running on the beach.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Our rear‐tether system
allows you to fall forward
and simulate real running.
No more dangerous
moving belts.
But we recognized with Sproing
we had a bigger opportunity
than just selling
fitness equipment,
so we leveraged
the versatility of Sproing
to break
into the studio market,
opening studios in Chicago,
Houston, and Baltimore.
Sharks, Sproing is the next
big thing in fitness.
Now everybody can train hard
and land soft.
We hear you all
are a little competitive.
So who's ready
to come on down
for a little friendly
competition, Sproing style?
‐I'll try!
‐Me!
‐Thank you. Appreciate it.
‐Yay!
‐Hey!
‐Come on in!
All right, we got
some shoes for you all.
Daymond, hold my jacket.
Thank you.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Daymond, you want
to do this one?
Lenz: Yeah. Come on over here.
Wrap around your waist there.
‐Okay.
‐Oh, it's full‐on.
Yeah.
I'm a lot thinner
than Daymond's should be.
[ Laughs ]
Okay, both of you, here we go.
Out at the end. Ready?
We're gonna do it
like a real class.
We run intervals.
Let's start running now.
Jog out.
‐Hold these, or...?
‐No, you can, but go ahead.
‐Keep the chest up.
‐10 seconds! Let's go!
Chest up. Chest up. Chest up.
‐10, 9...
Going in 5, 4, 3,
...2, 1.
‐There you go. Knees up.
‐Stop. Stop.
‐It's not moving.
‐There you go. Yeah.
‐No.
It's not a treadmill.
Lenz: Don't ‐‐ Don't kick
the heels back.
Knees forward.
Whoa!
[ Laughs ] You're moving.
‐So, we want you ‐‐
‐I'm basically running in spot?
Toback:
Well, think about it.
When you're running
on a treadmill,
you're not moving
anywhere, either.
This is the same thing.
All right, turn around.
Inside the belt, we're gonna
show you some versatility.
Okay, now we're
doing squat rows.
Okay, now, grab this.
‐So ‐‐
‐Will it hold me?
Yeah.
This holds up to 3,000 pounds.
You cannot pull out of it.
We got NFL guys,
NBA guys on this.
What am I doing?
You're gonna come
down into that squat.
We're gonna have you do a squat.
And then come
all the way back up and row.
And then pull. Yeah.
Cuban: Don't rip your pants,
Daymond.
Go ahead. Do it again.
‐Wow.
‐Pull. Yeah.
You know,
I really feel that.
We're doing intervals of cardio,
strength, and power.
We're changing every 30 seconds,
which is called tabata style,
the most effective way
to get your heart rate up.
We are running classes
with 60 intervals in 30 minutes.
‐Thank you.
‐10‐minute warm‐up,
5‐minute cool‐down.
So, in 45 minutes, you can burn
up to 1,000 calories.
It seems like they'd
be exhausted, though,
in 45 minutes, right?
Herjavec:
I got to tell you, you ‐‐
I thought it was
a bit of a joke.
Yeah.
But it's ‐‐
it's a great workout.
‐It's a real workout, yes.
‐We get that a ‐‐ We get that.
Why couldn't I simply
buy the mat
without all the rest of the ‐‐
which must be very expensive,
and just put it in my facility
with the two belts
that already exist?
Why not just sell the ‐‐
What's it called, the Sproing?
Why ‐‐ Like,
I don't even get this.
Because once you
go down that path,
you automatically get
to the end where we did, right?
You start with,
"Let's just put a mat down."
Well, you need
a rear tether system.
And I ‐‐ I ran into a guy once.
He said the same thing to me.
He said, "I'm gonna
put a mat in my yard."
I said, "Okay. Try it."
He goes, "Yeah, but then I need
to know how fast I'm going, so,"
he goes, "I need a footfall
sensor to figure it out."
He goes,
"Then I need a count."
I go, "Great. You're gonna end
right where we are."
‐How much does this cost?
‐You need the whole machine.
If I want to buy one for my gym,
how much?
$6,499.
‐Oh, my...
‐Whew!
It is right
in the sweet spot.
Commercial treadmills run
anywhere between $3,000 ‐‐
So, it's a high‐end
treadmill, very.
No. I used to be the CEO
of Bally Total Fitness.
Nice.
So we have depth
in this industry.
We have knowledge.
You do not see this anywhere.
So, can ‐‐ can we ask
Daymond and Robert ‐‐
how did you feel just running in
place? What did you think?
Well, it's like running in sand,
and it's really hard.
Like, it gets harder and harder
as you do it.
It ‐‐ It's a great
workout, Paul.
Thank you.
My challenge I was having there
is, on a treadmill,
you take it up,
you take it down.
You turn on the TV on there,
and you watch it
if you're walking in place
or doing other things.
This is for intense.
‐Yeah.
‐This is like ‐‐
Yeah, Paul, that's
my problem with it.
I'm not gonna do this
for 45 minutes.
Here's the focus
we have right now.
Okay.
We are opening studios,
high‐intensity ‐‐
Sorry. So, let's ‐‐
let's stop right there.
Sure.
You came out here
selling the machine,
but you're actually
selling studios now.
When I left Bally, I wanted
to invent a brand‐new machine.
There's only been five pieces
of cardio equipment
ever invented ‐‐
treadmill, elliptical, stepper,
bike, rower. That's it.
But how did you go
from this to a studio?
So, we went out,
and we started to
sell equipment.
How much of it
did you sell?
We sold about $1 million
worth of equipment.
That was in
a two‐year period.
We were meeting more resistance
than we thought, right?
This story has a ‐‐
Yeah, you're meeting
guys like me
that are very skeptical
about this.
Steve was the former head
of engineering at Life Fitness.
Yes.
He has more
treadmill patents,
more elliptical patents,
than any human being
on this planet.
And I was the biggest
buyer of treadmills.
So, what was the roadblock?
The treadmill manufacturers
have no incentive to innovate.
Here's what the health‐club
owners said ‐‐
"Eh, nobody's asked me
for this yet."
So, then who bought it?
We got ‐‐ We got some traction
in, uh, rehab centers.
We got some traction
in private training studios.
And we said, "You know what?
The uptake isn't
as fast as we'd like."
And all we kept saying
to ourselves was,
"Look, if we were still
running our company,
this is an amazing product
that would give us
a competitive edge.
We would replace
treadmills with this."
Got it. So, you said,
"We're gonna open up studios."
"We're gonna
open up studios."
How many studios
have you opened?
We've got four open
right now, in Chicago ‐‐
O'Leary: Only with these
machines in them?
‐Yes, sir.
‐Yes.
Are you making any money
in those studios?
The first full year
that we ran our Chicago club,
we had $400,000
worth of sales.
How much have you
invested in this,
and how much outside money
have you also brought in?
Yeah, 'cause that's
a complicated ‐‐
So, we've got about $2 million
of our own money into this.
Wow!
‐You're all‐in.
‐Your own money?
‐Our own money. Our own money.
‐We are all‐in.
‐Here's the problem.
‐Uh‐huh.
When I go to SoulCycle,
it's fun, it's intense,
it's motivating.
‐Right.
‐This isn't fun.
Okay, all due respect,
this is SoulCycle with running.
Here's wh‐‐
‐But how?!
‐So, that's what the class is.
It's a 45‐minute class.
There's 25 machines.
What we didn't get here
is the lights come down,
the music goes up,
the instructor's standing
in front of you ‐‐ "Let's go."
I sense your passion,
and that's great, okay?
Yeah.
I actually look at this
and say to myself,
"It's a dog."
You got to take it
behind the barn and shoot it.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐I was waiting for that.
‐It's a fact.
‐It's not a fact.
You stand in those clubs,
and you watch the hundreds
and then thousands of people
who've come through.
‐Oh, okay.
Cuban: Look, guys,
I would take this class.
When I go to Chicago,
I'll check it out.
‐It's great.
‐Good.
The challenge
for all of these,
they go like this,
and then everybody gets bored,
and then they move
to the next thing,
you know, just like
SoulCycle had its moment,
Barry's Bootcamp...
‐Right.
‐...Rise Nation, right?
Some of them stay longer,
but the bigger part
of the problem is,
because you're so
equipment‐driven,
it's gonna be harder for you
to adapt and change
in the future
as people's
expectations change,
and for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay. Mark,
I appreciate that,
and thank you
for hearing our story.
I would just say this.
We have had amazing results,
and the people
who take it love it.
Well ‐‐
Greiner: I get what
you're trying to do,
but I like consumer products.
I like it to be broader.
It's not a deal for me.
I'm out.
‐Okay.
‐All right, thanks, Lori.
I think that,
looking at your history,
you're not two bobos that
fell off a turnip truck, right?
Right.
You're, like, a guy who ran
the top retail, and then you ‐‐
So, why is it worth
over $6 million?
Well, I'ma tell ‐‐ I'ma tell you
why it's worth over $6 million.
Why?
Because they're both
very connected experts.
They've seen everything.
They've put in $2 million
of their own capital, and...
So?
...they are saying where
it's going to go next.
Why isn't it worth
$10 million, Daymond?
Let him finish.
It could be, but I'm just
telling you my opinion.
So, here is my ‐‐
here is my point.
Just 'cause
they have experience?
Here ‐‐ Here is my point.
Okay.
There's a lot of education
that's going to
have to make people aware
of this new type of workout.
I wouldn't be able to help you
where it's going
'cause you're the only one
with the passion
and the experience and the money
in there to do this yourselves,
so I'm out.
♪♪
You built a studio because
you had nowhere else
to sell your machine.
I don't want
to be in that business.
I‐I want to be part
of a movement in fitness.
Right.
I'm not sure
this is a movement.
This is a movement,
and I'll tell you why ‐‐
'cause what we did
the other way ‐‐
‐You didn't convince me today.
‐Well, I'm ‐‐
You didn't convince me today.
I'm ‐‐ I'm still
working on you.
‐I'm out.
‐Okay.
♪♪
O'Leary: I'm a numbers guy,
and it's very simple.
It's a dog.
The reason that they call me
Mr. Wonderful
is I tell the truth.
And I always make this offer
once a year,
and I think
this is it this year.
You can go to my cellar,
pick any bottle you want.
Some are worth $6,000.
Together, we drink it.
Let's drag this thing
around the back of the barn,
and I shoot it because you're
wasting your time with this.
What are you gonna do?
Oh, did I say I'm out?
‐No.
‐No, you were still talking.
Oh. Here we go.
I'm out.
Cuban: [ Chuckles ]
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Thank you.
‐Congrats, guys. Good luck.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Appreciate it.
‐Bye‐bye.
♪♪
Toback: We think
the Sharks totally missed it.
We think this is a
billion‐dollar opportunity,
and we think that
they just didn't see
where this could go
and how fast it can scale.
And so it's their loss,
and we're sorry
they didn't see it, but wait.
This is gonna be
an amazing company.
This sucks!
Are you kidding?
What about a treadmill?
This is better, from 1954.
[ Laughter ]
"Shark Tank" has enabled us
to grow our hair unfettered
and free from recrimination,
allowing us to advocate
for hair equality
while inspiring
strength and confidence
in men and boys
with long hair.
Here's to 200 episodes
and a decade of dreams.
[ Heavy metal music plays ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the tank
is a cost‐effective way to make
a trendy beverage at home.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Max Feber,
I'm from Detroit, Michigan,
and I'm seeking $50,000
for 25% of my company, BRUW.
I've perfected a new way to make
cold‐brew coffee at home
without the need for complicated
or overpriced equipment.
When I was just 15 years old,
I fell in love with coffee.
I tried making ‐‐
‐[ Laughing ] At 15?
‐15.
I tried making it, roasting it.
I did everything I could
to learn more about it.
One day, I stumbled across
cold‐brew coffee,
and I was dying to try it.
If you're not familiar
with cold‐brew,
it's a type of coffee
that's made in cold water
instead of hot water.
This doesn't extract the acidity
out of the coffee bean,
so it's smoother, it's sweeter,
and some even find that
it's easier on their stomachs.
After watching
countless videos online,
I found that people
use mason jars
to make it themselves
at home all the time.
‐Hmm.
‐So that's what I tried.
I took ground coffee
and cold water,
and I put it in a jar to let it
sit in my fridge for 24 hours.
Then I tried to filter it.
I used a cheesecloth,
a pour‐over, paper towels.
It just went everywhere.
It made this whole mess
all over my counter.
My parents were mad,
I didn't have my coffee,
and I wasn't about to spend
hundreds of dollars
on a complicated cold‐brew
coffee maker.
I knew there had to be
a better way.
So I ran into my garage,
I ripped a screen door
off the wall,
I grabbed a hot‐glue gun,
some mason‐jar lids,
and after some trial and error,
the first prototype
of BRUW was born.
Obviously, we've come
a long way since then.
So, let me show you
how it works.
First, you take some
ground coffee and cold water,
and you combine it
in a standard mason jar.
So, I'm just gonna fill it
all the way to the top
with the water,
and just a little bit of coffee
at the bottom's
really all you need.
Now I'm gonna put it in my
fridge to let it sit overnight.
That's really fast. Wow.
[ Laughter ]
So, now you take
the double‐sided BRUW filter,
and you insert it
straw‐side down
into the mason jar with coffee.
♪♪
Then you take an empty jar,
and you secure it to the top.
Oh.
Now just flip
and watch as your coffee
drips from the top jar,
through the filter
into the bottom jar,
giving you some delicious,
cold‐brew coffee.
♪♪
People love how simple
this method is.
But, Sharks, I need your help
to take me to the next level.
So, who wants to jump on board
and brew with me?
All right.
Good job, Max.
Can we try it, Max?
‐Of course.
‐Yeah.
I have some samples for you.
[ Quickly ] Do you think Max
is a little hyper 'cause of
drinking so much coffee?
I ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
‐Max, I have a question.
‐Of course.
‐How old are you now?
‐I'm 18 years old now.
So, you have
a cold‐brew coffee
that I actually made
in my hotel room last night...
How ‐‐
...because of how easy
the system is to use.
You made this 24 hours ago?
‐24 hours ago.
‐Okay.
I have the sugar cubes,
and I have some milk.
♪♪
Herjavec: Is ‐‐ Is ‐‐
Is this what it ‐‐
Oh, my God.
It's really strong.
Is this the normal
strength of it?
‐It's strong.
‐It's not strong enough for me.
Greiner: Really?
So, the benefit
of this system is,
because it's just a mason jar,
you can use as much or as little
coffee as you want.
So, I did it
the way I like it...
Oh.
...and I don't like it that,
like, overpowering.
‐Oh, I see.
‐But because ‐‐
But, Max, I'm Croatian.
We like our coffee ‐‐
So fill it up
all the way to the top,
just a drop of water.
You can just chew
on the grounds. It'll...
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Okay, so, how many people
actually go to the trouble
of making cold‐brew coffee?
Feber: I know that a lot
of large coffee retailers
have recently switched over
to cold‐brew coffee.
Peet's Coffee
has entirely changed
from iced coffee to cold‐brew.
I know Starbucks is
selling cold‐brew now in
addition to iced coffee,
and they're both selling
at $2 to $3 more than a normal
cup of iced coffee is.
Max, are you selling
the filter or the bottles?
Okay, our number‐one
best‐selling product
is that filter right there.
So that brown pouch
is the filter with the straw,
and it can hang ‐‐
‐How much does that sell for?
That sells for between
$15 and $20.
Cuban: Can we see that?
So, anybody could use
their own mason jar.
Exactly. Yeah, so,
any wide‐mouth mason jar.
You can find it at practically
any grocery store.
What does it cost you
to make it?
It costs us right now
$4 to make it in that package,
and with scale,
that's gonna drop to $1.50
with the new two‐cavity mold.
So, we're selling it
online right now.
Big‐box retail is what
we're aiming for in
the next year, and ‐‐
Where would you want to be
in a big‐box retail store?
So, this product
would do very well in,
you know, something like
a Bed Bath & Beyond or a Target.
Herjavec: Do you
have competition?
There are other
cold‐brew coffee makers.
They range anywhere
between $50 and $250.
And what do they do?
So, there's one that you put on
your counter and you add it ‐‐
You know, it's this big,
and you put it on your counter,
and it sits, and there's
a valve at the bottom
to, you know, filter it.
There's really nothing
that's designed
for somebody using a mason jar
that just wants to do it...
Max, I get the sense that
you're running at about 115%
and drinking a lot
of the product.
[ Laughter ]
Let's ‐‐ I‐I'm not kidding.
And I'm not saying
that's a bad thing,
but the numbers don't lie.
Why don't you tell us what ‐‐
what you've sold?
Last year,
we did $50,000 in revenue.
Okay.
And this year we're on track
to do $100,000 in revenue.
So, Max, are you
gonna go to college?
I'm in college.
I just finished my first year.
‐Where at?
‐Babson College.
‐Babson!
‐There you go.
I'm majoring in business.
Let me ask you this.
So, you're 18 years old.
How long have you been
watching "Shark Tank"?
Since I was about 8 years old.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Wow!
Watching "Shark Tank," I learned
how to run a business, right?
You see entrepreneurs
stand here, and they're,
you know, doing something
that might not be the smartest,
and they just
get roasted for it.
[ Laughter ]
And that's okay.
And so I'm taking the lessons
that you are telling
other entrepreneurs
and applying them
to this business.
The most inspiring thing
about being a Shark ‐‐
50% of the people that
come up to us are kids.
And they're learning
the language of business.
And look at you.
You ‐‐ You've taken that.
It's just so inspiring
to be a Shark
and to help people that way.
And he's augmented
with coffee ‐‐ a lot of it.
[ Laughter ]
So, I have a question.
Do you have a patent?
My patent was granted
five days ago.
What?!
So, pretty good timing,
I'd say.
‐Nice.
‐Wow.
‐Congratulations.
The patent was actually
done completely pro bono.
So, I reached out
to a patent firm,
one of the premier
patent firms in Michigan,
and I said,
"Hey, I'm a 16‐year‐old kid.
I invented this product.
Any chance you could
help me out?"
And they were
nice enough to say,
"You know what? Sure, kid, like,
we'll write a patent for you."
Oh, good for you.
Good for you.
Amazing.
Yeah, Max! Yeah, Max!
‐That is very hard to ‐‐
‐They did it? They did it?
That's what we call
the power of broke. I love it.
Max, maybe it's the coffee,
but you're really a dynamo.
I mean, you're coming
out here blasting.
Love the fact you've been
a fan for a decade.
Mm‐hmm.
But it's not a company.
It's a product.
You're not even a full CEO
because you're in school.
I'll give you the, um ‐‐
the 50K. I want 50%.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
‐How much is it?
‐Dang!
Mind if I hear
the rest of the room?
You didn't have an offer
two seconds ago. Now you do.
Well, I feel that this isn't
gonna be your big hit product.
I think you have
a lot more in you.
You're so smart ‐‐
and you're only 18 ‐‐
that I think
there's gonna be lots more,
and it only takes one.
It's a good idea,
but for me not the right
investment, so I'm out.
Thank you.
Herjavec: Max, tell me
what happens on day two.
$50,000 in the bank. Go.
So, we have the $50,000.
As soon as we have that,
we kick off the production
to get the cost of this
down dramatically.
But do you really think
that your problem is cost?
I do. If we have this made
and landed for $1.50
and we can sell this for $4.99
on a store shelf,
I think, you know, su‐‐
that's such a convenience buy.
Max, I'm so torn with this
because I‐I like you.
One of my top companies,
Bombas Socks ‐‐
they're from Babson.
They started off doing $800,000.
They're valued
at $150 million right now.
So I know you're gonna
figure it out.
But you don't know retail,
and you want to try
to get into retail.
♪♪
I would be interested
in trying to offer it
to a, you know, Peet's Coffee
or a Starbucks license,
so I would offer you
$50,000 for 30%.
Okay. Thank you.
Herjavec:
Max, I‐I love the hustle,
but I'm worried it's gonna be
a part‐time thing for you.
So, I'm working on this
all the time, all day.
No, I know you are, but ‐‐
I walk out of class,
I sit at my computer,
and I'm working on this.
Nonstop, I'm running this.
‐I respect the hustle.
I don't know if this
is a full‐time business.
For that reason, I'm out.
‐Appreciate it. Thank you.
Max, okay, so, when you look
at your gross margins,
you're selling it for $20
and making it for $4, right?
So you're $16
in gross margins.
So, why would you want
to take your margins down ‐‐
even if you get your cost
down to $1.50, right,
and sell it for $5
when you're making
enormous margins right now?
So, I'm still interested
in selling it at these
enormous margins.
Obviously,
it's a good price,
and people are buying it
at this price.
Right.
But I think that if this
was hanging in a store
at the register for $5.99,
$8.99, whatever it is,
and someone says,
"Oh, let me make some cold ‐‐
You know,
I make cold‐brew coffee,
I've heard of cold‐brew
coffee ‐‐"
But, again, why do you want
to sell more to make less?
So, I do just think
it'll be an impulse buy.
I think we're gonna
get more volume of sales.
I think more people are gonna be
buying this at the register.
More people will be
buying this online.
Max, you could test it.
Your assumptions may be wrong.
You could test it.
Look, I love when little
mini‐mes come out here, right?
[ Laughter ]
I‐I can see it.
I can feel it.
So, I like what you're doing.
‐Thank you.
I like the higher margins.
So are you open to focusing
on the higher margin,
as opposed to
pushing the price down?
Because instead of spending
the money on the new molds,
you could probably push
that into advertising.
‐I hear that. Yeah.
‐Okay.
I'll give you the 50K for 30%,
and I want to know now.
♪♪
‐Yes. You have a deal.
‐All right.
Ah!
‐Mazel tov.
‐Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Appreciate it, buddy.
Thank you.
Guys, it's
the coolest thing!
‐Ever.
‐Congrats.
‐Whoo‐hoo!
‐Ever.
Thank you so much.
We got a deal! [ Chuckles ]
I've been watching "Shark Tank"
since I was 8 years old,
and now to finally have a deal
with one of the Sharks I've
been watching since I was a
little kid and aspiring to
is just unbelievable.
I'm so ‐‐
It's a dream come true.
This is the most incredible
experience that I've ever had.
He's exactly why
we do the show.
Entrepreneurship, the American
dream is alive and well.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
is an accessory
to help carry
your most precious cargo.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Tammy Rant,
and I'm from the suburbs
of Northern California.
And I'm here today
seeking $200,000
for 10% of my company, TushBaby.
♪♪
[ Baby babbles ]
I've created the simplest
and most comfortable way
to carry your kids
because life's hard enough.
Carrying your kids shouldn't be.
I'm a mother of two,
and, as you can see,
I've got another on the way,
which means I've got a kid
attached to my hip
majority of the time.
I found myself sticking out
my hip to carry them,
which quickly got uncomfortable
and painful on my back and arms.
And trying to leave the house
with them and a diaper bag?
Forget it. I'd rather stay home.
So I went out looking
for something to help me,
and all I could find
was a complicated,
hot, bulky,
strap‐in baby carrier
that's often more
of a hassle than it's worth.
That's when I created TushBaby.
TushBaby is a simple seat
that sits right on your hip.
It's just one buckle
with two safeguards.
As you can see, it only takes
seconds to put on.
Greiner:
[ Chuckles ] Are ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
Ooh! Pretty cool.
‐Cute.
‐That's cool.
Our ergonomic hip seat
puts your baby's hips
in the proper M‐shape position
that's recommended
by pediatricians,
so it's totally safe
for little ones.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Aww.
The waistband evenly distributes
the weight
while the seat absorbs
some of it,
making it comfortable
to carry your kids
without popping out your hip
or putting strain
on your back and arms.
Kids love to sit on the TushBaby
'cause it's soft and squishy
on their cute little tushies
and they're free to hang out
while you hold on.
TushBaby has four storage
pockets,
which means you can leave
your purse,
diaper bag, and stroller
in the minivan.
♪♪
‐Aha!
‐[ Chuckles ]
Ta‐da.
It's got a loop here
to attach a toy,
and this bad boy folds up
so you can take it on the go
or store it away.
TushBaby's a huge
problem‐solver, and
I've designed it
with the uncomfortable
and overwhelmed parent in mind.
Now, who wants to grab a Tush?
I've got samples for you.
‐Can I try?
‐Yeah.
Yes, I'd love that.
‐Does that make you Tush Daddy?
‐Tush Daddy.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Okay.
Herjavec: All right,
all right, put it on.
So, you just wrap it
around your waist.
Okay. Hi!
Now, Robert, you're
used to carrying babies
since you've got...
I'm used
to carrying babies.
...five now total, altogether.
Hi. Aww.
So, you see how heavy he is,
right?
Look at the scary Sharks.
All right, so,
he's pretty heavy.
Keep it up here tight,
and you just hold him in.
‐Okay.
‐Don't drop the baby, Robert.
And you hold on.
See, put your arm around him.
‐Oh, down here?
‐Yeah.
What's his name?
‐This is Ben.
‐Hi, Ben.
Oh, that's pretty good,
yeah!
He's about to fall off, Robert.
[ Laughs ]
Herjavec: Yeah,
it's pretty good.
You have
to wear it higher.
Yeah, you've got it
a little low.
That was the key.
So, you kind of
want it a little ‐‐
I had it low
the first time, yeah.
That was my fault.
Okay.
Can we see the samples?
[ Laughing ]
‐Thank you.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Mr. Wonderful.
‐Thank you very much.
Sure thing.
‐Thank you, thank you.
‐Thank you.
I think we can say bye
to babies.
‐Bye, Tush Daddy.
‐Bye, babies.
‐Bye.
‐Bye‐bye, baby.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Tammy, how much is it?
$21.81 is the landed price,
and I'm retailing for $79
with free shipping
in the United States.
‐$21.81.
‐Are you all direct‐to‐consumer?
Right now, yes.
‐On your website?
‐Yes.
How many have you sold?
So, we've sold about 2,500.
We just launched five weeks ago.
‐Wow.
‐2,500 units?
‐Yes.
‐Wow.
‐Holy crap.
‐So...
‐Congrats.
‐Nice!
‐Really nice.
Was there any P. R.‐type push
to push that?
‐It went viral.
‐How did it go viral?
So, a ‐‐ a couple big
media outlets posted it ‐‐
BuzzFeed Parents, um,
Daily Mail.
With parents, right,
particularly dads like me,
when my kids were really tiny,
everything was an adventure.
Right.
And you could see
with Robert holding Ben,
right, his ‐‐ his tush
was halfway off.
Right.
What ‐‐ What are the complaints
that you're getting online,
or what are the risk factors
that you're concerned about?
TushBaby is a parent's helper.
It's not a replacement
for active parenting.
Hmm.
So, it's like
other products on the market,
like specific types of chairs...
‐But ‐‐ But don't you think ‐‐
I mean, have you had instances
where you can swing and miss?
We're worried about
dropping babies.
We're just ‐‐ Yeah, 'cause
Ben was sliding out,
so I'm just curious
if that's been a concern
that you've heard
from customers.
Not from customers before, no.
‐Okay, that's good.
‐It's a concern I had.
We did do market research
and had test trials,
and then we refined the product
based on the feedback.
Have you shipped yet, though?
‐No. So, I ‐‐
‐Ohh.
How many people have these?
Um, about 25.
So, the comments ‐‐ are any of
the comments coming from the 25
that are actually
using this first product?
Oh, yeah, I mean, I did ext‐‐
I've been
developing it for a year
and enhancing the product.
We've had 12 different
prototypes.
How much money
have you raised?
I raised $75,000 for 5%
very early on
before I even launched or even
had my final prototype done.
Good for you.
Friends and family or...
Yeah, it was
a good family friend.
The reason I need the money
is to place a really large order
so I can get ahead
of my pre‐order situation,
and the way that
it's going right now,
I'm selling over 500 a week.
And I'm gonna be sold out
of my pre‐orders
that I already have ordered
before they even get here.
‐What's your background?
‐Yeah.
So, I'm an enterprise
sales rep for LinkedIn.
Are you still doing that
for LinkedIn, or are you ‐‐
‐So, for a couple more months.
‐You have three kids. [ Laughs ]
A couple more months,
I'm gonna be at LinkedIn still,
and then after that, um, 100% ‐‐
‐Running this.
I wake up every morning
at 5:00 a. m., work on TushBaby,
go to LinkedIn, come home,
take my kids for a couple hours,
put them to bed,
work 'til midnight,
and then I do plan on expanding
for October when the baby's due.
I'm gonna have
an assistant start.
I'm really impressed
with what you did.
Thank you.
And I'm impressed
with you. I mean...
[ Greiner laughs ]
‐Thank you.
‐...two babies, one on the way,
still working at a company,
a wife,
running another company,
starting it.
I mean, I think you work
harder than me, so...
Thank you.
‐That's not saying much.
‐That's true.
‐Yeah, that's not hard.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Yeah.
‐So, Tammy ‐‐
You know, I've put my life
into this. I ‐‐
That's true, but I‐I have
an offer for you, Tammy, so ‐‐
Oh! There's an offer.
‐I have an offer for you, Tammy.
‐Oh.
$200,000 for 10%.
You want to take the offer?
Well, wait a second.
You may have other offers.
I ‐‐
‐You may lose this one.
‐Yeah. That's okay.
Tammy,
let me clear things up.
You're incredibly impressive.
I think it's a great product.
My concern is,
it's a singular product,
as opposed to an entire
product line.
And you haven't
actually delivered any.
Right.
So ‐‐ So, to me,
it just seems risky.
I'm not saying
you can't do it.
Just not something
for me today.
I'm out.
Well, thank you
for your consideration.
I have an offer for you.
I'll offer you
the $200,000 for 15%
because I bring a lot more value
than Daymond does.
[ Laughter ]
So ‐‐
Kevin, what's the value
you bring?
A lot. I would ‐‐
I would ‐‐
See, I still have a baby
with a diaper. You'll have
a partner with a diaper.
You know,
I‐I recently brought
another baby product
into my portfolio,
so I'm now just working on
a whole lot of social for it.
But anybody that's
holding a child this way
would use this product,
so I'm starting to see a lot
of synergies between those two.
You'll start to notice now
when you're out more often
that there's parents
carrying their babies
like this all the time.
There's no solution
for quick carrying.
So, Tammy, you ‐‐ Tammy ‐‐
Cuban: No, this
would have been great.
When my kids were young,
this would have been amazing.
Tammy, you have two offers.
I'm offering you exactly
what you asked for, right?
Thank you, and I ‐‐
I would love to ask you
if I could listen
to all the other offers
because I think you want a
partner that is not impulsive,
makes thorough ‐‐
I want a partner who's decisive,
and I asked ‐‐
I offered you
exactly what you asked for.
And, Tammy, I'll ‐‐
I'll simplify it. Look.
There's three industries
that I avoid like the plague ‐‐
the music industry,
pet industry...
It sounds like
he's about to drop out.
...and the kids industry.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
Well, you have two offers.
Lori, what are you doing?
Lori, I would love
to hear your thoughts.
Greiner: Um, well,
let me tell you.
I think your product's
really clever.
My only concern is,
we don't know yet
what the consumer's gonna say
or feel when they get it home.
And so for those reasons,
it's just too early for me
as an investor.
Oh, Lori. I‐I hope
that you know ‐‐
So, I've had it t‐‐
a lot of people wear it.
Everybody loves it,
and it exists ‐‐
But you only have
25 people testing it.
The final prototype.
I've had hundreds test
all the way along the way.
Tammy, Sharks want to feel
like we're adding value
and we're being valued.
I already told you that you
were risking us dropping out.
I'm gonna adjust my offer
to $200,000 for 15%.
I'm gonna match
Kevin's offer.
Lori, did you drop out?
I didn't hear you drop out.
‐No, she hasn't.
Are you ‐‐ Are you
definitely out, Lori?
Have you said you're in or out?
What are you doing?
Well, I‐I was saying
that my concern
is what the consumer's going
to say once they get it home.
I'd be willing to get a rush
order up, you know, fly it in...
I'm almost begging her
not to screw up these
offers right here.
...and test it so that ‐‐
on a bigger scale.
Have you even thought about
having a seat belt...
Tammy, do you want
an offer or not?
‐...or a security belt?
‐I do.
Because I'm ‐‐ I'm tired of...
Tammy, Tammy, I believe
you're here for ‐‐
Cuban:
Sometimes great salespeople
have to learn to stop selling.
All right.
I believe you're here for Lori,
so I'm gonna drop out.
Oh. Sorry, Daymond.
I‐I would have loved
to partner with you...
I understand, but I can
see that you already had
in mind probably Lori.
...but I just really want
to explore all the options.
Wow!
So, real‐‐ real‐‐
really fast ‐‐
I can't believe
you did that.
I‐I don't want to lose his
offer, but I ‐‐ I think ‐‐
‐But you did.
‐You got to make your decision.
It can't ‐‐ Real quick,
you can add straps to it.
It's something that
I've considered.
I really wanted to focus
on brand equity...
Tammy, I'm not
feeling the love.
...and getting a novel
product to the market,
and then I will be
adding straps down the line
and an extension belt
so it can fit other people.
‐Tammy, I'm out.
‐Please ‐‐ Okay ‐‐ No, no, no.
‐I'm out.
‐Please!
You pissed me off. I'm out.
Narrator: Four Sharks are out.
Tammy had two offers on
the table from Daymond and Kevin
for her baby carrier, TushBaby,
but her indecisiveness
has made her lose both.
‐Tammy, I'm out.
‐Please ‐‐ Okay ‐‐ No, no, no.
‐I'm out.
‐Please!
You pissed me off. I'm out.
[ Sighs ]
You don't sell someone else
when they're not there for you.
‐I wanted you together.
And there's only one
Mr. Wonderful.
Now, you better
talk her into the deal...
Wow.
...or you walk out of here
with nothing.
I'm done with you.
I'm sorry.
Give your best shot
to Lori now.
You better
give her a deal, Lori,
'cause I'm out, he's out.
‐Would you do $200,000 for 15%?
This is gonna be the number‐one
item on baby registries.
You're the perfect
partner for me.
I would love to have worked
with both of you.
My concern is,
is the risk of putting...
Are you in or out, Lori?
We've heard this already.
...the money in.
Be considerate to her.
Stop interrupting, Kev.
Come on.
‐This is her big moment.
‐Yeah.
She's standing on this carpet,
and it means...
I think she just
blew her big moment.
‐...everything to her.
‐No, she didn't.
She came here for Lori,
and she has a shot. Go ahead.
We are gonna make
a lot together on this.
This is ‐‐ I promise you.
People love it.
They do. They love it.
It's ‐‐ It's ‐‐
I've gotten reached out to
by orthopedists, pediatricians.
And the users ‐‐ they love it.
It's ‐‐ It's something
that ‐‐ It's a ‐‐
There's a real need
for it on the market,
and I know we can
blow it out together.
You are the quality of a partner
that I really like,
the product is really smart,
but because of the risk,
I would be most comfortable
doing $200,000 at 20%.
♪♪
You got a deal.
‐Oh! Well.
‐That's decisive.
‐Wow.
‐I'm decisive. I ‐‐ Thank you.
You're smart.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Okay. You're welcome.
I'm so excited
to work with you.
You're welcome.
Oh, good, good, good.
Okay. All right. Good.
Thank you.
‐Congratulations, Tammy.
‐Bye.
‐Thank you so much, everybody.
‐Congratulations.
‐Congrats.
‐Thank you.
♪♪
Rant: I came here for Lori.
I risked everything for Lori.
I'm so happy
to have her on board.
She is the Shark
that I wanted all along,
and I was willing to
give up other offers
with better valuations
to have Lori on my team,
and I'm so excited
to partner with her.
When I see somebody
that's indecisive,
I don't want to work with them.
‐She wasn't indecisive.
‐I think she was decisive.
She came in here
looking for Lori.
No, no, she was scrambling.
You know what they teach you
in enterprise sales?
When you have the order,
you know what you do?
Stop talking.
‐You take it. You stop talking.
♪♪